[DIGITAL EFFECTS]
NANCY KANWISHER: So
let's start with one
of the deepest questions humans
have ever asked themselves.
We're not messing around in
this class; we're going for it.
And one of the
deepest questions is,
where does knowledge come from?
And as you'll know, if
you've taken even a teeny bit
of philosophy or read
even a teeny bit,
you know that some of the
classic views in Western
philosophy-- especially the
empiricists, Locke and Hume--
argue that all knowledge
comes from experience, right?
On the other hand,
there are a number
of other schools of thought in
Western philosophy, of which
a dominant figure is
Immanuel Kant, who
argued that experience
alone is not enough.
You can't just have experience
and figure out all the stuff
we have figured out.
And so he argued that there
has to be what he called
"a priori conditions"
of cognition, which
can't be derived from
experience themselves,
but have to be given
prior to it, OK?
So you have to have to build
some structure into a mind
or brain to get
it off the ground.
You can't just start
with absolutely nothing
and get anywhere.
OK, and he also argued that
one of the key elements of this
a priori structure that
you have to build in
was space and time--
organizing principles of
cognition and thinking.
And so in his
version of it, space
is nothing but the form of all
appearances of outer sense,
and it can be given prior to
all actual perceptions and so
exist in the mind a
priori, and can contain,
prior to all experience,
principles which determine
the relations of these objects.
OK, well, is that just
empty philosophical hot air?
It's kind of hard to understand
exactly what he means.
You're actually have to go
spend a good deal of time
with reading him to
make any sense of it--
or cheat and get your
friends to tell you, as I do.
But no, I'll argue it's not just
empty philosophical hot air--
that these are, in
some important sense,
empirical questions.
And there are
empirical questions
that our field
addresses very directly.
And so on Wednesday,
we'll talk about
whether your representations of
space in your head are innate
or not.
It's pretty much directly
what Kant is talking about--
or the modern version of
what he was talking about.
And today, we'll talk about
which aspects of the brain
are innate and which
our learned, OK?
That's the agenda.
OK, so this little kind of
Easter egg brain here very
schematically shows
you some of the regions
that we've been talking
about in this class
so far, with regions that
are, to varying degrees,
specialized for processing
things like shape, and color,
and motion, and faces,
and places, and bodies--
visually processing all of
these things in approximately
those locations.
And as I've mentioned,
these regions
are present in approximately
the same location--
with some individual
variability-- in pretty
much every normal person.
One of my lab members
says, you keep saying that,
and it's just not true.
There's some percent
of subjects who
just don't show these things.
He's kind of right, OK.
So maybe, I don't know,
5%, 10% of subjects,
you wouldn't see
some of these things.
And we've never actually
done the serious work
of bringing those subjects back,
scanning the hell out of them,
and finding out whether they
were just asleep in the scanner
or it was a bad scanner
day, or whatever it was.
I bet they all have them,
and it's just sometimes
you don't see it, but I'm trying
to be a little more honest.
OK, but you just look at this.
Given this very
schematic version of it,
you say, how would
you build this system?
How would you start with an
embryo and build into a genome,
or build into
whatever experience
is going to happen to
this developing organism?
How would it end up with this
very particular structure,
with those things in
approximately the same place--
or at least the same relative
positions-- in all subjects?
The face bits are always
lateral to the color bits.
The place bits are
medial to the color bits.
The shape bits are out
on the lateral surface.
It's like always like that.
How do you build a
system like that?
I find it hard not to
immediately think, well,
some aspect of this
must be innate,
or how would it be so damn
similar in each individual,
right?
But it's not the
only hypothesis.
Some big part of it-- even if
some aspect of this is innate,
some big part of it may
also be learned or derived
from experience, OK?
So what do you guys think?
Do you think the fact
that these structures
are in systematically the
same place across subjects
mean you have to build
in all that stuff,
somehow figure out how
to get a bunch of As
and Ts and Gs and Cs in your DNA
to give you a blueprint for how
to build that structure?
What do you think?
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: I mean,
it's a combination,
but it's hard to, then,
think about how that's
involved in
[INAUDIBLE] generation
and then kind of
become more innate?
NANCY KANWISHER: Yeah, so
to some extent, experience--
what I mean here is
learn from experience
within each individual.
You could argue
that "innate" really
means "learned through the
experience of our ancestors,
and hence wired
into the DNA," yeah.
Anyway, I find this not
an obvious question,
and so we'll talk about
what the data say here.
So first of all, we're going
to do some very basic facts
about brain development, just
to get the picture of what
we're talking about physically
with the development of brains.
So we can ask, what
is present at birth?
And so it turns out that most of
the neurons in the adult brain
are generated before birth, OK?
So most of the actual
neurons are generated early.
You're not making a whole
lot more after birth--
a few, but not a lot.
Further, the current view is
that most of the long-range
connections-- that means like
a connection between this part
and that part of the brain--
are also present at birth, OK?
Nonetheless, even though a lot
of stuff is present at birth,
a lot of stuff changes in the
first couple of years of life.
Most obviously, the
brain doubles in volume
in the first year,
from a two-week-old,
to a one-year-old,
to a two-year-old.
The cortical thickness-- you
can see here the dark stuff,
which is the gray
matter out there--
increases sharply between
years one and two.
But also, the complexity
of each individual neuron
increases dramatically in
the first few years of life.
So here's a schematic picture
of a piece of gray matter here.
We have some number
of neurons here
with a few little processes
and a few connections.
And over the first
couple of years of life,
those connections
get much more dense,
and the neurons get
much more complex.
OK, and the final
thing that really
matters early on in development
is that myelination happens
rapidly in the first few years.
And remember, myelin--
this is a little reminder--
neuron with that yellow stuff,
which is a bunch of cells
that wrap around the axons,
the long processes of a neuron.
And that myelin
sheath builds up a lot
over the first couple of years.
And that's important, because
the myelin sheath enables
those neurons to send
their signals faster
down their axons, OK?
OK, and this is just a
picture of different--
of a vertical slice like
this through the anatomy
of infants of different ages,
from 107 days up to about a
year.
And the colored
stuff in the middle
is degree of
myelination, which you
can see with various
kinds of anatomical scans.
You can see it starts at 107
days with a tiny little bit
in the middle, and it gets
more and more myelinated
and moves from
center to periphery
over the first year of life.
So all those fiber
pathways are getting
accelerated as they get wrapped
with myelin and hence sped up.
OK, all right, so bottom
line is most neurons
and long-range connections
are in place at birth,
but development continues
rapidly in the first two years,
especially increasing complexity
of neurons and synapses
and myelination of long-range
connections and white matter,
OK?
So it's just basic anatomy,
nothing functional yet.
OK, now we're going to
consider in some detail
the case of face perception,
not really because that's
what I work on--
or used to work on, mostly--
but just because
there's a very rich set
of data where people have
grappled with this question
in the case of face perception.
Next time, we'll talk about
the navigation network
and reorientation-- what parts
of that system might be innate
and learned.
So I'll just say right
out of the beginning
that this is an extremely
active area, where every time I
turn around, another paper
comes out that contradicts
a previously-published finding.
And so that makes
it fun, but it means
there isn't going to be some
really tight, perfect story
here.
And I'd rather take you guys
straight to the cutting edge,
even though it's kind of a mess,
than give you a nicely packaged
but surely wrong picture, OK?
Because again, I think what
matters most in this area
is how do you go about
answering these questions,
rather than what is the
current state of the thoughts
about the answers.
OK, so how are we going
to think about, how
does face perception develop?
Well just to get
started, I'm going
to show you a very brief
movie of a 72-hour-old monkey,
and see what you think.
He's sleepy.
He's pretty interested
in that face.
And watch now.
Hmm.
[LAUGHS] Pretty cute, huh?
So what do you think?
What does this tell us
about face perception?
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: Did they try
just moving anything
in front of him?
NANCY KANWISHER: Good question.
Good for you.
Quily, is that right?
AUDIENCE: "Quile-y"
NANCY KANWISHER:
"Quile-y", all right.
Yes, so Quiley asked, did
they try moving just anything
in front of him?
Absolutely the right question.
So that monkey seems pretty
interested in that face,
but a face is a moving thing.
Motion is very salient to young
primates-- humans, and monkeys,
and many others, absolutely.
What else did you see in here?
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: It started
imitating [INAUDIBLE]..
NANCY KANWISHER: Yeah, kind of.
I mean, the person--
the adult human there--
was moving their mouth open
like this, and the monkey
was doing something
with their mouth.
So what would that require?
Sorry?
AUDIENCE: I like,
I have another.
Also, was the monkey allowed
to touch its face before this?
NANCY KANWISHER:
Yeah, good question.
Good question.
72 hours is damned early,
but it's not zero experience,
right?
So who knows what they've
managed to pick up that early.
There are actually
studies in humans,
which I'm hoping Heather
knows better than me.
Those Andy Melzoff things.
How young are those humans?
Those are like first hour.
AUDIENCE: Yeah, [INAUDIBLE].
NANCY KANWISHER:
I think it's a--
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
NANCY KANWISHER: So
there are studies
in humans where you can
show versions of that,
with newborn infants copying--
the experimenter comes up
and sticks their tongue out
at the infant, and the infant
does that back, kinda sorta.
Certainly within the first two
days, maybe even earlier, OK?
OK, so it's very suggestive.
It's tantalizing, but we
need controlled conditions.
It doesn't tell us
everything we need to know.
OK, so if we think
about it, there
are ends of the hypothesis space
about how all of this could go.
As Alana mentioned, everything
is both genes and experience.
That's true, but there
are very, very importantly
different ways in which
genes and experience can
act together-- some in which
a big part of the heft of what
the adult form has
might be built in,
and other stories where
most of the structure
comes from experience.
So just because everything
is both doesn't mean
we shouldn't flesh out
exactly what comes from what.
So on one end of
the spectrum, you
might imagine that there's
some very, very rudimentary
precursor that has to be built
in, plus a learning mechanism,
OK?
Or a bunch of
rudimentary precursors,
which are just there
to get the system
to learn in the right way, OK?
And so we'll talk
shortly about the idea
that there might be some kind
of innate template for faces
that gets monkeys and
humans to look at faces.
And then, the idea is once you
get them to look at a face,
then experience can take over
from there and do the rest.
But you've got to get them
to collect the right input.
And there's lots of interesting
computational work going on now
where people are using various
computational models to say,
what do we have to
build into, say,
a convolutional neural
network or some other kind
of computational model to get
it to do some complicated thing?
I just came from a job talk
the last hour-- really amazing
talk-- where the guy is
showing that if you build
in, basically, curiosity
early on in a network,
you get much more general
learners than if you
build in a bunch of goals for
a developing network to seek.
anyway it's a very active
area, and the paper
that I just decided
to assign to you guys,
just kind of skim
it and get the gist.
The basic idea-- this
is from Shimon Ullman,
who is a very deep
thinker in this field.
And he argues that hands are
very important in infants.
Faces are important, but so are
hands, because hands do stuff.
And we're social
primates, and we
want to learn from other social
primates like our parents.
And watching their hands
is extremely informative.
Whatever they're
doing with their hands
is probably stuff we
need to learn about.
And further, we need to know
where they're looking, right?
So gaze perception.
I think I did this demo before.
If I'm talking to you guys,
and I start doing that,
it's really hard, even though
you know I'm just faking you
out, not to have your
attention pulled over there,
and infants need to
learn that as well.
So Shimon Ullman's
basic idea is that you
can start with an extremely
rudimentary system,
and all you have to build
in is this idea that he
calls "mover," right?
So the idea is that if you look
in a whole set of, say, YouTube
videos, and you just look
for patches of the image that
are moving, that's no good.
It won't be a hand.
It might be a whole animal,
or a face, or something else.
But if you look
in YouTube videos,
a proxy for natural experience--
it's OK; it's not perfect,
but it's something- you look
for a patch of the image that
moves over and then causes
another previously-stationary
image patch to move.
That's what happens when
we pick stuff up, OK?
And so his idea is you can
build in this extremely simple
thing--
Mover, which is a very
simple visual algorithm,
can find image patches and move
over and cause another image
patch--
or then the two image
patches move together.
And Mover will enable you
to identify hands in images
pretty well.
He looks in YouTube
videos and shows
that it's really good
at picking out hands.
And then, further, once
you've picked out hands,
that's a really
important teaching signal
in teaching you to read gaze.
Because often, people
look at their hands
before they do things
with them, yeah?
So the idea is there's a
very active ferment now
in computational
modeling saying,
how can we start with just the
most rudimentary, minimalist
stuff that has to be built in,
and then build on experience
to get the rest from there?
Is that idea clear?
It's worth reading
that paper, though.
It's beautifully written.
He's brilliant.
OK, so that's one
end of the spectrum.
Nobody thinks that you
learn absolutely everything
from experience.
You've got to
build in something.
Plus, we know all those
neurons are there at birth.
And so the idea
is some version--
the minimalist
nativist view says
you build in a few very
rudimentary things,
and they're enough to
bootstrap learning.
OK, on the other end of the
spectrum, you might think--
and many have
proposed-- that we're
born with a nearly
adult-like system that
only needs fine-tuning
from experience, right?
Nobody thinks that zero
experience is necessary.
That would be kind of
crazy, or implausible.
But on the other extreme, this
view is that most of the stuff
is built-in.
OK, everybody get the
theoretical space here
that we're considering?
OK, so what kind of data can
constrain these questions?
Well, one obvious question
is, what is present at birth?
What is the initial state--
or as close as we can get to it?
Then we can ask, how does
the system change over time
from birth onward?
And then we can ask, what are
the causal roles of experience
and biological maturation
in that change after birth?
So that's the whole
set of questions
we'd need to answer to
understand how development
works.
And a very central-- if
not the central-- challenge
of development is that
experience and maturation are
deeply confounded as you look
from birth onward, right?
So five-year-olds are
both more mature--
they've had more time for
their biological systems
to wire themselves up, including
their bodies, and their brains,
and the whole bit--
and maybe some of that
is just on a maturation
kind of autopilot.
But they've also had
a lot more experience.
So one of the central
challenges of development
is trying to figure out
how those later stages--
like two months old, one
year old, 10 years old--
how those changes that happen
between birth and those stages
can--
how can we tease apart which of
that came from just maturation
and which came from experience?
All right, OK.
Importantly, things that
happen well after birth
need not be learned, right?
So think about puberty.
Puberty is going to
happen around 10, 11, 12.
And OK, you've got
to eat and have
some basic inputs
to your system,
but it's pretty much
going to happen.
It's not a product of
what you were taught
or the particular
information that landed
on your sensory receptors.
I'm sure there's some
obscure influences that I
don't know about,
but mostly, it's
on a developmental autopilot.
It's just going to happen.
OK, so keep in mind--
this is really important--
that things that
happen well after birth
aren't necessarily learned.
It might be just maturation
that's continuing, right?
OK, just as being 5 feet tall
versus a foot and 1/2 tall
isn't really learned.
It's just a maturation
program that unfolds.
OK, so we can ask these three
questions both behaviorally
and naturally.
And ultimately, we want
them to tell the same story.
When I said there's some
chaos in this field right now,
I mean that basically, they're
not converging very well yet,
but that's fun--
sort of.
[LAUGHS] Sometimes
it's aggravating,
but mostly, it's fun.
OK, so let's start with
some behavioral data.
So let's consider
the initial state
of face perception in newborns.
OK, so we can ask, what kind
of perceptual, face perceptual
abilities are
present in newborns?
And we can ask whether they
can detect a face-- that
is, discriminate a
face from a non-face,
whether it's a body, or an
object, or something else.
We can ask about preferred
attention to faces.
Do they, do newborns
want to look at faces
more than non-faces?
We can ask about the
ability to recognize faces,
to discriminate one
face from another, OK?
And we can ask about the
ability to recognize faces
across image changes.
So we spent a lot of time
in the first few lectures
talking about the central
problem of invariance
in vision--
about, how do you know
that this image that you're
looking at here is the
same person as that image,
even though those are
very different images?
And actually, this image
on your retina right
now is more different than
this image on your retina
than if we got one of you and
came up-- had you come up here
and had you look forward.
So the image changes that result
from a change in orientation
are greater than the
image changes that result
from a change in identity.
So it's a big
computational challenge.
When is that solved?
And then, there are these
so-called signatures
of face perception
that we've talked
about a little bit-- for
example, the inversion effect.
Recall the inversion effect
is larger in magnitude
for faces than non-faces.
So we can ask when
those things develop.
OK, so let's start
with face detection
and preferred
attention to faces.
Well, so classic
studies from the early
'90s, and actually, some of
them going back to the '70s,
did the following
very low-tech thing--
a low-tech drawing of
a low-tech experiment.
You take a newborn infant.
In this case, they're less
than an hour old, right?
You've got to set up
in maternity wards.
You want the data,
that's what you do.
Of course, you have to ask
the parents and all of that.
But then, you take this
infant and you sit them
on a person's lap with
a video camera overhead,
and you move different objects
over the infant's head, OK?
And the different objects
that were moved, in this case,
were patterns that were
drawn on this paddle that's
moved over the infant's head.
And the pattern could be a
schematic face like that,
a scrambled schematic
face like that,
and a blank with nothing in it.
And what you measure is,
how far does the infant
turn their head or their eyes
following that paddle as you
move it over them.
OK, nice low-tech measure.
And what you find is they turn
their heads and their eyes
farther when it's an actual
schematic face than when it's
a scrambled schematic face or a
blank, within an hour of birth.
Then you can still say,
well, their parents probably
smiled at them quickly before
they were snatched away
to do the experiment, so they
had some face experience,
but boy, not a whole lot.
And this is a very
abstract face here.
So this has long been taken as
one of the key bits of evidence
that something seems likely
to be innate about faces, OK?
But now, what needs
to be innate for that?
And it's a bizarre thing, where
this happens in the first two
months of life and goes away.
And there's a lot
of consideration
of what that means.
Maybe the first two months
is enough to bootstrap
learning in the way
I was just talking
about-- bootstrapping, getting
attention to the right places.
But there's also a huge
literature on this phenomenon
where there's a big
debate about exactly how
simple those cues need to be.
So people have done
many variations of this
and one dominant story
is that all you need
is a pattern that has more stuff
on the top than on the bottom,
OK?
And that's enough
that infants will
follow this more than that.
And the idea is that in
the visual environment
of an infant, that's
sufficient to pick out faces.
So there's been pushback
against this view as well.
It's probably a little
more complicated than that.
We won't go down the rabbit
hole of all those details,
but whatever it is,
it's pretty simple.
So this is another example of
what I was mentioning before
with the Ullman case.
This is a case where it
may be possible to build
in something pretty basic--
a pretty basic
template-- and then
let learning take it from there.
Make sense?
If the infants are
looking at faces,
then they can use some kind of
synaptic plasticity, whatever,
and learn from their
experience to discriminate
one face from another.
OK, so these things are
present within a day or two.
What about discrimination
of individual identity?
First problem, how
are we going to be
able to tell what
a newborn can see?
And so I didn't
want you guys to be
to thrown by this method
in the last assignment,
so I told you where there's a
version of the explanation I'm
just going to give.
So if you already watched
that, my apologies.
You can read your
email for a minute.
So the classic experiment--
a classic experiment--
that enabled
us to really ask how a newborn,
non-verbal infant, what
they see in the world, is
done by Kellman and Spelke.
Liz Spelke up at Harvard
was at the forefront
of getting this method
to really tell us
a huge great deal about what
infants see and understand
about the world.
And this method that
I'm about to show to you
has been the basis of what's
sometimes called "The Infancy
Revolution," which is basically
the insight that, actually,
infants know a lot.
Their perceptual systems
are really sophisticated.
They know about physics.
They know all kinds
of social stuff.
Within a few months of
life, they know a lot.
And that's been a radical
change in our understanding
of development based on
just behavioral work.
So here's the method.
OK, so what Spelke did--
I always forget
to bring the demo.
Hang on one moment.
We don't need much.
OK, so she showed infants
stuff like this, OK?
The two hands are not there.
You just arranged
to see this, OK?
So even if you hadn't
seen me, imagine
if you hadn't seen me pick
up the phone and the pen,
and you didn't already
know what they were,
and you're seeing this, OK?
That's what they see, OK?
So now, the question is,
when infants see that,
do they think that that's this--
thing behind a rectangle--
or do they think it's
two separate bits moving
behind the rectangle?
It could be two separate
bits moving together, right?
Everybody get the question?
OK, so how would we know
what the infants thought
was back there?
OK, well, we use what's known
as habituation of looking time.
Again, you sit the
infant on a parent's lap,
and you show them
stuff, and you just
measure how long they look.
It's magnificently low-tech
but really profound.
OK, so what we're
going to show here
is how long the infant looks
on each trial as a function
of how many times you do it.
So you show the infant
this the first time,
and they look for 40 seconds.
That's a long time.
You show them again, they look
for 35 seconds, and so forth.
And by the fifth or sixth
time, the infant is bored.
Like been there, done
that, bored, right?
OK, now they're bored.
Now we have a moment to say,
OK, what did you think it was?
And so now, what you can
ask is, what do they think--
you then show them
either this or this,
and you ask them which of
those they're bored to, right?
So the idea is if,
when looking at this,
they thought there
was a continuous line
behind the occluder, then they
should be more bored by this.
But if they thought that was
two separate pieces, then
they should be
more bored by that.
Does that makes sense?
Because it's the same thing
they're already bored with.
I mean, it's not
exactly the same.
The occluder isn't there, right?
But it's more similar.
OK, so here's the data.
Here's what they find.
So what does that mean?
What do the infants see
when you show them this?
It's right there in the data.
Look at the first
test trial here.
This is the first
test trial, when
you show the complete
line or the broken line.
What do they see here?
Yeah, they saw the complete one.
That's why, when you present
the complete one again,
they're still bored--
already saw that.
Make sense?
So isn't that awesome?
It's so low-tech and
so simple, but this
is how you can ask an
infant, what do you see?
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: Why does it switch
positions in the second trial?
NANCY KANWISHER: You know,
frankly, I never understand
why infant and
development people do
a second and third trial.
Seems to me by this
point, the jig is up.
I think it's just because it's
hard to get enough infants,
and you need more
data, and so they
do a second and third trial.
But to me, that's
the diagnostic one.
And that's probably not
a significant switch,
but whatever's going on
out there is obviously
much less important than this.
Heather, do you have a
better answer than that?
Why do they do
those other trials?
They always do, and it
just seems like, what?
[LAUGHS]
AUDIENCE: I don't know.
NANCY KANWISHER:
Yeah, I don't either.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]?
NANCY KANWISHER: Oh, you
do it every which way,
but you do it pretty fast.
They get bored, and you don't
want to wait half an hour
and come back, right?
I mean, you could do that.
Then that would be a
memory question, right?
Yeah, Jimmy.
AUDIENCE: Just curious,
is this conserved
between [INAUDIBLE] do they
all see complete lines, where
[INAUDIBLE]?
NANCY KANWISHER:
It's pretty robust.
Well, OK, so first
of all, these methods
are awesome, that you can
learn these deep things
about perception in infants.
But these data
are noisy as hell.
There's no error
bars on this plot,
but I bet if there were, you'd
have to run a lot of infants
to get to the point where
you reach significance.
Because a lot of times, the
infants will just throw up,
or they'll just do what-- they
do all kinds of random things.
So the data are extremely
noisy, and it's very hard
to get enough data
with an infant
to say anything about the
difference between one
infant and another.
By the way, there's a very
exciting development going on
in this department
right now, where
Kim Scott, who's a former grad
student of this department,
has figured out how to do
looking time experiments
like this online, OK?
And that's hugely important,
because the number one
bottleneck in this kind
of developmental research
has been finding enough
infants, or getting
enough data per infant.
And so I think that she's going
to just crack it wide open.
Talia?
AUDIENCE: I guess I'm
a little bit confused
how we know what the infant
really saw based on how long it
looked at something.
Could it be that maybe
they look at like--
maybe they look at the
broken sticks longer,
because it's like what
they thought was behind it,
so they're now excited that
they get to see what's--
NANCY KANWISHER: Maybe, but
then, why would you get this?
So we know from this that
the more familiar it looks,
the less time they look.
So you would have to
come up with-- yeah,
there's wiggle
room in these data,
but you'd have to come--
your account would have
to say, why would they
look less, and less,
and less long when we repeat
the exact same thing, right?
And you could tell a
story like, OK, it's
a little bit different, because
the occluder isn't there.
But it's a little bit
the same, and that's
kind of edgy and fun.
Or you could tell
another story, but I
think the bulk of the
developmental literature
shows that when you
do this kind of stuff,
it's a change that
makes infants look more.
I'm going to go on unless there
are questions of clarification,
just because there's so
much other cool stuff.
OK, so how can we use this
to study face recognition?
That was just a
sidebar on the method.
OK, so there's a
lab in Italy where
they have an infant psychology
lab next to a maternity ward,
and they've been doing
all these awesome studies.
OK, and they test
1-3-day-old infants.
And so one of the
things they did
is show infants, just like the
paradigm I just showed you.
They show the infant the
same face again, and again,
and again.
That's the habituation phase.
And then, this is a
slightly different one.
You give them a choice
of whether they--
actually, you don't
give them a choice.
I take it back.
Yeah, you show this
condition or that condition,
and you see how long
they look at each
across different infants.
And so this is the same person
from a different viewpoint.
Actually, pretty subtle, as
we discussed with the Jenkins
study way back.
And that's a different
person from that viewpoint.
And what they found is
that-- it's hard to see,
but a very low P level
means that there's
a significant
difference in how much
the infants looked at those two.
So that's pretty amazing.
1-3-day-old infants can
apparently recognize
the identity of a face, a novel
individual they don't already
know, with similar-looking
faces, without hair,
and across view changes.
Wow, right?
So that's pretty impressive.
OK, and so then, they've done
all kinds of other variants.
If you have them rotate all
the way from front profile,
there's no longer a
significant difference.
Infants can't do that.
And then they do all
kinds of other variants.
If you show them the
same individual and then
habituate to that, they
can tell the difference
between viewpoint.
That's the same, and
that's different,
even though it's
the same identity.
So you can use this
to test what they
think is same or different,
which is a deep question
to ask.
If you're interested in
representations and cognition,
the question of what an
infant, or an animal,
or a bunch of neurons thinks
is the same or different
is the essence of characterizing
what it represents.
Yeah, Quiley?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE] the
rotated face [INAUDIBLE]??
NANCY KANWISHER: Down here?
Yeah.
Yeah, they do.
So here, basically,
it's either identical,
or it's different
in some respect.
So given a choice, when
it's rotated anyway,
the familiar one
is more similar.
But down here, this one is
more similar in viewpoint.
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: And these are
not like the [INAUDIBLE]
in such [INAUDIBLE] the
student, the [INAUDIBLE]
NANCY KANWISHER:
Sorry, say it again?
They're not like--
AUDIENCE: The children have
seen faces before this.
NANCY KANWISHER: Well,
as little as possible.
As I say, I mean, they've
seen some, but not very many,
and they haven't
seen these faces.
So when you're trying to get
those innateness questions,
you go as close to
birth as you can,
but you can't usually
go into the very moment
of birth itself, right?
And so there's usually
some experience,
and it's a challenge,
but this is pretty early.
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: So couldn't that just
meant that the face perception
network is just like--
it develops really quickly,
right after [INAUDIBLE]..
NANCY KANWISHER:
It could, it could.
Based on these data
alone, it could.
That's considered
kind of unlikely,
but I agree that that's
consistent with these data.
In the first two days
of life, the whole thing
wires itself up.
That's be pretty unusual.
It's not really consistent
with those samples of neurons
that people have looked
at elsewhere in the brain,
but maybe there's a special
little circuit that just
wires itself up really fast.
So not likely, but possible, OK?
All right, now, you might
say, well, maybe there's
some kind of simple
visual features
that are short of an actual
face representation here.
This doesn't show us that
this is something about faces
per se, even though it can
generalize across viewpoints.
So it's not just pixel
intensity, right?
So what is the
classic way we asked
this question in face
perception, where we ask,
is this really something
about faces, or is it
something about the low-level
perceptual properties
of the face?
AUDIENCE: Turn it upside down?
NANCY KANWISHER: Yeah,
turn it upside down.
God's gift to the face
researcher, right?
So-- oh, I guess that
was not on this slide.
OK, right?
OK, so now, in the
next experiment,
they present whole faces, or
just the internal features
without hair, or just the
external features without hair.
So the infants can
do that at the top.
They know those
two are different.
They can do this here, and
they can do that there.
OK, not too shocking yet.
Just tells you any of those
cues can support performance.
But now, we can ask, is
that just pattern-matching?
No, it's not.
Because when you turn
them upside down,
you find that only--
let's see, it's only
performance in this case that
suffers when you turn
them upside-down,
not this case or that case.
OK, so that shows that there
are a variety of cues here that
infants could be using, but when
you show them just the internal
features-- the
actual face proper--
that part, the ability to
do this discrimination,
goes away when you
turn it upside down.
So that part, at least,
seems to be at least somewhat
face-specific, or
has the signature
of face-specific processing.
Make sense?
OK, I mean, as a
pattern, it'd be just as
easy to recognize
this upside-down
and distinguish it
from that upside-down,
if it was just the pixels
you were registering.
But if you were doing
face processing that's
something like adult
face processing,
you'd expect that
inversion effect.
OK, all right, so where are we?
And I should just say, even
this is actively debated.
In fact, the author
of this study
considers this
not to be evidence
that that processing
is face-specific.
I think she's got some of
the strongest evidence ever,
but she's got some
counterargument
about how in the inverted
faces, they don't look
as long in the situation phase.
And so it's like I'm telling
you these cool methods,
but boy, every one of
them can be fought over.
OK, so where are?
We've just shown
that discrimination
of individual identity is
present in very young newborns,
recognition across viewpoints,
and inversion effects
are all present within the
first few days of life.
OK, so newborns have very
impressive face perception
abilities, and that's
particularly surprising
given that their acuity
is terrible, right?
the vision is really
blurry for young infants,
so it's amazing that
they can do these things.
But now, there's room for
quibbling about whether this is
really a face-specific system.
So the inversion
effect is suggestive,
but they haven't totally
nailed the case about what's
being tapped into here.
Is it really face
perception per se--
something specific
to face perception--
or is it some more generic
kind of object perception?
OK, and further, we want to
know what happens after that.
OK, so you don't need
to memorize this table.
I'm just going to make a
few simple points with it.
There are lots and
lots of studies
where people have tested
behaviorally all kinds
of different aspects
of face perception,
and the basic story
is that by age four,
you see the little
smiley face means
that this adult-like property
of the face perception system
is present by age four.
So all of those signatures
of face perception
that are present in adults
are present by age four, OK?
And in fact, much of the
action is much before that.
You can see that
all of these things
are present at the earliest
age they've ever been tested.
The little square means
nobody's tested it at that age.
So all this stuff is
developing very fast, right?
OK, one particularly
important thing
here that you read
about a little bit,
but that I want to take a moment
to make sure you understand
because it's so
interesting and cool,
is the phenomenon of
perceptual narrowing, OK?
And this happens
in face perception,
and it happens in phoneme
perception in speech.
And I'm going to do a demo here.
So I'm going to show you
a monkey face briefly.
OK, it's going to
come on in a second,
and you just look at It.
Here we go.
Boom, there it is, OK?
OK, in a moment, I'm going to
show you another monkey face,
and you're going
to shout out same
if you think it's the
same, and different
if you think it's different,
and, huh, if you don't know.
How many people don't know?
Yeah, it's different, right?
OK, well, OK, maybe
that was too hard.
Let's try it with a human, OK?
Remember how hard that was?
Now let's try it
with a human face.
I'm going to show
you a human face.
Everybody ready?
Here we go.
OK?
OK, and I'm going to
show you another human,
and you're going to say,
is it same or different?
Here we go.
Duh!
Easy, right?
OK, so here's the amazing thing.
You were better at
that monkey face task
when you were six months old.
You could do that
monkey face task
when you were six months old.
One of the things that you
have learned from experience
is that you don't
need that information,
and you threw away your
ability to do that,
but you had it when you
were six months old.
Isn't that awesome
and interesting?
That's called
perceptual narrowing.
So the experiments, in
particular, do the following.
You use that preferential
looking paradigm--
the preferential looking to
the novel face in infants--
as your measure of
discrimination ability.
What can they discriminate?
And so you show
two human faces--
two different
individuals, like this.
And so now, what you see is
that at six months, nine months,
and adulthood,
people preferentially
look to the novel face more
than the familiar face, OK?
That's just what
we've just done.
People like to look at the new
thing, not the old thing, OK?
However, if we do six months,
nine months-- oh, yeah,
that's what we just said.
OK, they can do that.
So now, if you try
this on monkey faces,
you find that
adults are like us.
We're barely able to tell
the familiar from the novel.
We're not so good at
monkey face discrimination.
Nine-months-old are the same.
But at six months,
infants can discriminate
the monkey faces, and you could,
too, if somebody had asked you.
So there's a very similar
phenomena with phonemes.
Those of you who are not
native speakers of English
maybe aware of some
phonemes in English,
if you learned it relatively
late, that are hard for you
to discriminate.
There are sounds in Hindi--
I forget, it's like
a "da" and a "ta,"
that sound identical to me, but
that are just like completely
obviously different to
native Hindi speakers.
And all languages have this.
So of the kinds of phonemes
that are discriminated
in any language
in the world, you
could discriminate all of those
when you were six months old.
And one of the
things you do when
you learn a language
is just throw together
in the same bag things
that are actually
different that other
people can discriminate
if your language doesn't
discriminate it, OK?
And so you get
that with phonemes,
and you get it with faces.
OK, everybody get what
perceptual narrowing is?
OK.
OK, you also get this--
I mentioned this way back--
with perceiving faces
of other races, right?
Not just faces of other
species, but if you grow up
in an environment
where you're only
exposed to races A, B,
and C, and you later
have to discriminate
faces of races
D, E, and F, you're not
so good at it, right?
All the same deal.
OK, all right.
So how would we know whether
this change between six months
and older is just
maturation-- it's just
some kind of
developmental program
that's going on autopilot
independent of what you see,
or whether it's learned
from experience?
Josh?
AUDIENCE: You control
for experience.
NANCY KANWISHER: You control
for experience, absolutely,
like the Sugita paper.
OK, so we'll get to
that in a second.
So we started with these
key questions-- what
is the initial state
at birth, and we
showed impressive perceptual
abilities within a few days,
although people dispute
whether those abilities are
a face-specific system.
And we don't know much about
what that system is, other
than it works surprisingly
well given the low acuity.
And we showed that how
it changes after that,
there's perceptual narrowing
between six and 12 months,
but a great deal is not known
about what happens then.
And so now, we're
onto this question
of how are we going
to un-confound
what changes after
birth, whether it's
maturation or experience.
And I'm not going
to have time to get
to these other awesome methods.
We're going to focus on
controlled rearing, of what you
read the Sugita paper.
OK, so just to remind you
of the basics, most of you
seemed to get the
paper just fine.
The big idea was again, using
this preferential looking
method, what Sugita et al.
Showed is that when they
reared monkeys for six, 12,
or 24 months without ever
letting them see a face,
and then tested them on
the very first session
that they ever saw faces
with preferential looking,
they found that on the very
first exposure to faces,
the monkeys looked more at
faces compared to novel objects,
right?
They showed that face
preference, sort of akin
to infants looking
at the paddle,
and they discriminated
between faces--
very similar faces--
with adult-like accuracy.
And this part, I don't know
if you found it surprising,
but when this paper came
out I, was like, whoa,
that is crazy, right?
Because as I said, the whole
space of sensible hypotheses
is, OK, maybe a lot
of stuff is innate,
but you're still going to
need experience to tone it up,
for God's sake, right?
Who would think the entire
adult ability could exist
without any experience at all?
So I don't know if
you had that reaction,
but I think that's
a sensible reaction.
It's a pretty astonishing
finding in that paper.
Unfortunately, there's
one author on that paper.
It was done once, and it's
such a labor-intensive study
that probably nobody will
ever try to replicate it.
So in the back of many
people's minds is like, really?
Can that really be true, or
is there something funny here?
So I hope somebody
replicates it someday,
but it hasn't been done yet.
OK, the other thing that
you guys presumably noticed
is there was perceptual
narrowing in that study.
There were many interesting
things in there.
It's actually
quite a rich paper.
But after the initial
testing session,
no matter how long
the deprivation,
the monkeys were then housed in
either an environment with just
humans or just monkeys.
And so whether that
was 6, 12, or 24 months
after birth of face
deprivation, they then
lost their ability,
at that point,
to discriminate the
unexperienced faces, OK?
So they went through
perceptual narrowing.
Does that all make
sense to you guys?
You got that?
Good.
OK, all right.
So anyway, that suggests
that an awful lot of the face
perception system is present
without any exposure to faces,
and that's pretty astonishing.
What experience
seems to do there
is not create abilities,
but eliminate them
right for the species
that you don't see.
OK, so first
reaction is, really?
Second reaction,
is there any way
to account for this in terms of
some non-face-specific system?
I think you can, but
it takes some work,
and the counter-explanations are
really difficult. You can say,
well, maybe this is all
being carried by some more
generic object system.
They didn't test inverted
faces, unfortunately,
but if it was carried by
a generic object system,
why would you find the
perceptual narrowing?
Why would they have
lost their ability
for the unexperienced species?
So I think that story
is hard to tell.
And, of course,
the other question
I'm sure you guys
are wondering is,
what is going on in
those monkeys' brains?
Yeah, OK, so let's get to that.
Let's talk about what we
know about development
of this system by
looking at brains.
And first of all,
there's been lots of work
on this in older kids, age 5 and
up, going back over a decade.
And it's now clear that
all of that basic machinery
I showed you is present by age
five, in most kids age five.
It's continuing to
change after that,
but you can detect most of
that stuff by age five, or six,
or seven-- something like that.
OK, trouble is, that's
cool, but age five
is late with respect to
experience and with respect
to all those behavioral
abilities that I showed you.
So we need to go earlier.
And so a couple of years
ago, Rebecca Sachs--
who's straight up
there, two floors up--
started scanning infants, OK?
And this is-- as Heather can
tell you-- almost impossible.
It is right on the edge.
It took Rebecca and her lab
many, many years of work
over five years just to
get the system going.
There were all kinds
of technical advances,
like making scanning coils
that were optimized for infants
and comfortable for infants.
Rebecca herself went
to great lengths,
including producing some
of her own subjects.
That's her son Arthur
there and her two--
her grad student and postdoc
who were working with her.
But all of this massive
effort was worth it,
because what they found
was, first, for comparison,
this is adults with a contrast
of faces versus scenes, OK?
So this is basically the PPA in
blue responding more to scenes,
and the FFA in here and some
other face-selective bits
responding more to
faces in adults.
What do you see in
six-month-old infants?
It's astonishingly
similar, right?
You can really see a
very similar layout
of the functional
organization of the brain
already by six months.
So that's a huge advance.
That pushes way back
the timeline by which
these things had developed.
Previously, everybody
is talking about, oh,
what changes after age five?
Age five, come on?
OK, it's mostly
there by age six.
OK, now, importantly, these
systems are not adult-like.
Their selectivities
are very different.
Those regions are less
selective in infants
than they are in adults.
But the spatial layout is
there already by six months,
and that, importantly,
constrains--
whatever our model
is of development
that pushes it way back.
OK, so now, the
next questions are,
what is it about that region--
or those particular
regions-- that
makes them become face-specific
already by six months?
How does the face
system know to take up
residence in that systematic
location in the brain,
and what is the
role of experience
in their construction?
And how could we
ever answer this?
One way to answer that is
to use an animal model, OK?
So there's been-- yes.
AUDIENCE: OK, yeah,
similar question about--
NANCY KANWISHER: I'm
sorry, I didn't hear.
About what?
AUDIENCE: General
physical layout--
like why does your stomach
always come in the same place,
and would it maybe be
the same mechanism that
guides development of any organs
and the layout of the body,
[INAUDIBLE]?
NANCY KANWISHER: Yes.
Now, I don't know much about how
hearts, and kidneys, and livers
develop, but my understanding
is that's pretty much wired in.
There's some chunks of DNA that
tell you how to build a kidney
and where to put it
in your body, right?
And so that is one of
the hypotheses here.
It's a tempting
hypothesis, right?
There's all that structure.
It's a very tempting
hypothesis, but that doesn't
mean it's necessarily right.
Yeah, it absolutely is.
It's a hypothesis we should
consider and take seriously,
yeah.
OK, so but we want data.
We want to find out.
OK, so animal models.
So starting a few years
ago, Marge Livingstone over
at Harvard Med
School over there--
a couple of miles over there--
started doing these
also really amazingly
heroic studies where she
was scanning infant monkeys.
OK, now, this is
really hard to read,
so let me tell you
what we got here.
We have the cortex.
This is all the same animal
at different time points,
and each of these
things is the cortex
unfolded mathematically
and flattened
so you can see the whole thing.
I don't expect you
to know what's where.
I can barely tell myself.
But if you look at it, what
you see is at 81 days of age,
there's just blue stuff.
There's no orange stuff.
The orange stuff is the
face-selective response.
In fact, if you
look down, you start
to see, oh, that looks--
yeah, yeah, OK, that
looks pretty systematic.
It starts replicating
after that.
And so the claim is you
don't see face selectivity
until about 170 days
after birth in monkeys.
OK, that's about here.
Here's another monkey
for comparison.
If you stare at
it, you'll see, OK,
there's these systematic
bits-- boom, boom, boom, boom--
and maybe a little hint
at 170, but-- there's
some garbage up there, but
nothing systematic before that.
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: So there's no
control of the environment?
This is like monkeys--
NANCY KANWISHER:
Normal monkeys who
have exposure to human faces
and monkey faces hanging out
in the lab, yeah.
We haven't gotten to
control rearing yet.
It's coming.
OK, first thing is just, when
does it develop in monkeys?
OK, all right.
So are you surprised by this?
It's not there here,
and it is there there.
You should be surprised.
Why are you surprised?
This is what you guys predicted.
Quiley?
AUDIENCE: I guess I'm
surprised because they
were able to discriminate.
NANCY KANWISHER: Yeah,
what is up with that?
Absolutely!
The Sugida paper really made
it look like that system was
innate, right?
No experience-- boom!
They're fine.
It was just behavior, but it
was a good behavioral study.
So why the hell isn't it here?
Everybody with the program
on how surprising that is?
OK, so a bunch of things.
First of all-- and it
gets stable after that,
and replicable.
Well, the first thing is
one's a behavioral measure,
and one's a neural measure.
Maybe those fabulous
behavioral measures
weren't actually being driven
by some face-specific system.
Wouldn't that be sad, right?
I mean, they did
lots of controls.
It was a nice idea.
I thought they did as well
as they could, but who knows?
Maybe those monkeys
could do that task
with some other system and they
didn't need their face system
for it.
That's one possibility, right?
Then, you could have the face
system not develop till later,
but the monkeys
could do it before.
But the other thing
is, notice that Sugita
didn't test their monkeys
until, with the youngest ones,
six months of age.
So maybe it just got
wired up just before--
right there-- they
were tested, OK?
So it seemed
contradictory at first,
but it's not completely,
literally contradictory, yeah?
OK, all right, so now, the fact
that this stuff doesn't show up
until here, does that mean
that this face system requires
experience to develop?
You know the answer, because
whenever I ask that question,
the answer is always no.
Why does that not imply
that you need experience
with faces to wire up?
It's tempting.
You look at it,
and it's like, OK,
you had to look at
faces all this time
before you wired it up.
Boom, there it is--
very tempting.
But-- is it Jessica, no?
Sorry, what's your name?
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: Bele.
NANCY KANWISHER: Bele.
Oh, sorry, you told me
that like six times.
AUDIENCE: I could be merely
due to mature, physical.
NANCY KANWISHER: Yeah, it
could be just maturation.
I keep making the same point,
because it's important, right?
Just because it shows
up later doesn't
mean it's learned, right?
Maybe it's like puberty,
or height, or something
like that that's on some
developmental program that's
just going to unfold
independent of what you see, OK?
So how would we find out?
We would do controlled rearing.
And that's exactly what
these guys did, OK?
So in another paper that just
came out a couple of years ago,
they raised baby monkeys without
ever letting them see a face.
Much like Sugita did,
they use welder's masks
every time they were in the
lab, so the monkeys never
got to see faces.
And like Sugita,
they went to lengths
to treat the monkeys nicely.
They heard the calls
of their com-specifics,
they got lots of attention,
they had rich visual experience.
They just didn't see faces.
So it sounds kind of tragic
and horrible at first,
but it's actually not that bad.
They had social contact
and visual experience.
They just never saw faces--
both this study and
the Sugita study.
All right, OK, so they could
hear and smell other monkeys.
So the face-deprived
monkeys saw no faces at all
until 90 days old.
And at that point, they went
straight into the scanner, OK?
And the first time they
saw faces was inside an MRI
machine getting scanned, OK?
So what do you think?
Are the face-deprived monkeys
going to show face patches?
So there's no way
to tell, because we
have all these contradictory
bits of evidence here, right?
From Sugita, you
might think yes.
Hard to tell.
So let's just look at the data.
OK So here first is a normally
normally reared monkey
260 days old just
for comparison.
And those face patches in yellow
in two different monkeys here,
B4 and B5, left and
right hemisphere.
OK, so those yellow bits
are the face patches.
OK, normal 260-day-old monkey.
Now we're going to see
a face-deprived monkey,
260 days old.
This monkey was face-deprived
that entire time up
until scanning.
No face patches.
The plot thickens-- no
face patches at all.
So these guys published this
paper in a very high-profile
journal and said--
this is the title of paper--
"Seeing faces is necessary for
face-domain formation," OK?
Face domain just means
face-selective patch.
OK, everybody see?
You deprive them of face
experience, you don't see it.
OK, that's pretty
interesting, and it strongly
suggests that the face system
is not innate but depends
on face experience, doesn't it?
Rare case where the
answer is, yes, it does.
And it feels like it contradicts
the Sugita finding, right?
But not exactly.
You could still wiggle
out of it, right?
You could say, OK,
the thing that Sugita
was studying doesn't
use those patches,
so it's not flat
out contradictory.
Sugita was measuring
behavior; these guys
are looking at brains.
So it's kind of unsatisfying,
but it's, in principle,
possible.
Me and everyone else has
been nudging these guys
to run the Sugita behavioral
experiment on your monkeys,
please!
And I gather that's
getting going,
but I haven't seen
any of the data yet.
So we don't know how
that's going to resolve.
OK, so let's take stock.
What is the initial state?
We show with behavior
that there is
both attention to faces and--
present in newborn humans, and
face specificity seems like it,
but it's not totally nailed,
whereas functional MRI says
there's no evidence for
face specificity at birth--
at least in monkeys, right?
That's other.
Yeah, OK, so how are we
going to reconcile this
with all the behavioral
results I showed you,
that there seems to be
a lot of face abilities
present in newborns?
Well, one possibility is
that face specificity exists
behaviorally, but MRI fails--
oh, sorry, face specificity
exists in the brain, but
MRI fails to detect it.
There's a whole rigmarole about
whether functional MRI works
well in infants.
It's barely possible,
as I mentioned.
It's also hard with
infant monkeys.
Their blood flow
regulation is different.
They're squirming and wiggling.
There are a million issues
with scanning babies,
whether human or monkey.
And so you could always
say, well, it was there,
and just the MRI data
are just kind of crappy,
or blood flow
regulation to the brain
develops later-- an argument
many people have made.
However, a paper was
published last week
that argues against
that hypothesis.
The same group just showed
that the somatosensory touch
system is totally in place
by 11 days in baby monkeys.
So that suggests that you can
get really nice functional MRI
data at 11 days of
age in baby monkeys,
and it makes it less
likely that this
is some kind of spurious
failure to detect something
that was actually there.
I'm not going to test you
on every little detail here.
I want you to think
about the logic of how
you can ask these questions.
OK, the other possibility
is that the face abilities
that we showed behaviorally are
using some more generic object
recognition system, not using
this face-selective system
in the brain.
OK, so how does it
change over time?
Well, we showed
that behaviorally--
in humans, at least--
all the hallmarks
of face-specific processing
or present by age four,
and we get this perceptual
narrowing between six and 12
months.
But then we showed that
with functional MRI--
at least in monkeys--
there's no evidence for face
specificity before 200 days,
right?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]?
NANCY KANWISHER: I gather
they're working on it,
but I haven't seen any
of the data yet, yeah.
OK, so that lack
of face specificity
is consistent with
the idea that all
that human early face
recognition behavior
is driven by a
different system--
because they don't have their
face system yet, presumably.
But it's also consistent
with this idea
that it's just failing
to be detected.
Even though I said
that's probably not true,
given you can detect other
stuff, it might be true here.
The ability to see
things with MRI
depends where you're
looking at the brain.
OK, so what about
these causal roles
of structured experience
and biological maturation?
OK, so we argued that
early face experience
isn't crucial for the
face recognition system.
That was the Sugita
paper you read.
But now, functional MRI is
showing that face experience
is necessary for the development
of face patches, at least
in monkeys.
And so a very sensible
reaction, is what, what, what?
How are we going to
make sense of this?
This is a big conundrum.
It's going to get worse on
Monday, where there's yet
more contradictory data.
And further, if that
face system isn't innate,
then what, if anything, is
innate about face perception,
right?
So maybe what all these data are
telling us is, not that much.
Maybe just a biased
look at faces,
or some very simple
image template
that's sufficient in the
environment of infants
to get them to look at faces.
So there's a lot of
studies I didn't have time
to work into this lecture,
where people stick cameras
on the foreheads of
newborns, and they
collect, what is the typical
visual experience of a newborn?
And then, you can take that--
you can take that experience
and ask, what kind of--
you can write
machine learning code
to say, what would you have to
build in to reliably pick out
the faces in typical
infant input?
And it's probably
not that complicated,
because infants don't see that
many different kinds of things,
right?
OK.
We showed early visual
discrimination abilities
of faces in newborn infants.
But again, it's not
clear that's part
of the face-specific system.
And we showed that
the face patches--
at least in monkeys--
seem to require experience, OK?
I'm just recapping here.
But now, there's
this big question of,
how do those face patches know
where to develop in the brain?
Like here they are in humans,
these little purple blobs.
The occipital face area I've
got two different fusiform face
areas, because various
people think there's two.
I'm not sure.
I don't really care;
doesn't matter.
Anyway, how do they know
to land right there?
OK, we keep bringing up this
question and dancing around it,
but so far, I've given no
basis for thinking about this.
One possibility
is that infants--
monkey and humans-- are
born with some earlier
kind of selectivity of
that patch of brain.
It's not a whole face template.
It's not a whole face system.
Maybe it's a bias for
curvy things, right?
And then, somehow, that
makes the faces land there,
and the system wires itself up.
It's not exactly clear
how that would go.
But that's one kind of story.
Another story is
based on this fact
I told you at the beginning
of the lecture, which
is most of the long-range
connectivity of the brain is
present at birth.
And so maybe the
particular connections
of that patch of brain are
already there at birth,
and maybe that
patch of connections
are sufficient to somehow
gate the input to that system
and arrange for it to end
up being face-specific, OK?
So this is a very active
area of investigation,
and there's other very active,
ongoing kinds of investigation
where people are trying
to understand how
this development might work.
One way people are
looking at this--
I mentioned this
briefly, but I think
it's super exciting--
is people are asking
with deep nets and other
kinds of modeling, what
do you have to build into a
system to get it to produce
face recognition abilities?
If you're trying
to make a deep net,
you're trying to make it really
good at face recognition,
do you need to give it
a template of faces?
Do you need to give it
only experience with faces?
What do you need to
build into it to get
it to be really good, right?
And so that's a very active
area of investigation.
And you can actually-- with some
ongoing work with Jim DiCarlo's
lab, we're asking, OK, deep
nets don't have topography.
Next door units in a deep net
doesn't mean anything, what's
next door versus far apart.
Location doesn't mean
anything in a deep net,
but you can make
it mean something.
And then you can ask when,
and whether, and how,
and why you get face patches
in a deep net and what
computational role they serve.
Well, totally weirdly,
I'm finishing early,
but I'm not going to finish.
I'll take questions,
and then I'll
maybe add a little bit more.
I think that was all
I had here, right.
Any questions about all this?
If it feels a
little bit chaotic--
I've sort of said
x and not x, and x,
although they're not
exactly x and not x.
They're just-- yeah, Sirdul.
AUDIENCE: So the fMRI tends
to [INAUDIBLE] activity
in boxes, right?
[INAUDIBLE] you said
contain millions of neurons.
So is it possible
that the neurons
that are specific to
faces are distributed
at an early age throughout
the brain, and somehow
the function for them--
NANCY KANWISHER: They
get spatially clustered.
AUDIENCE: Yeah, but
the neurons themselves
already exist at birth?
NANCY KANWISHER: Absolutely.
That's a great hypothesis.
It's absolutely possible.
Everybody get the idea?
You have all those
face neurons at birth,
and maybe they're
face-specific at birth,
but they're
spatially spread out.
And then they have
to find each other
and hang out together
next to each other
before you ever
get an MRI signal.
It's totally possible logically.
It seems to be quite
unlikely actually,
because it would be very
hard for all those neurons,
with their necessary
connections-- which is,
after all, how they
become face-specific,
is what their inputs are and
what they're connected to--
it'd be very hard for
them to migrate spatially
across the brain maintaining
their connections.
Yes, you're going to push back?
Go for it.
AUDIENCE: Well, I
think [INAUDIBLE]
But since you said
[INAUDIBLE],, they
care about what their
neighbors are doing.
So maybe it's just like
a neighboring neuron's
properties, but the
[INAUDIBLE] in this chain
moves it back until
that brief [INAUDIBLE]..
But that progression is the
most efficient way to pop up.
NANCY KANWISHER: It's totally
possible, totally possible,
absolutely.
Yep, other questions?
And this is wide open.
Nobody knows, right?
Let me just see what else
I have time for briefly.
So funny, I took
out all these slides
because I just thought I'm
not going to run out of time,
and go over, and
drive everyone crazy.
I moved all this stuff
to the other lecture.
Maybe I will just--
All right, hang on,
let me just glance
at the lineup for Wednesday.
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: Is there--
the perceptual narrowing
is really surprising
and fascinating.
Does anybody have a model for
how that processing might work
or what it might be for?
I mean, it feels
like a lot of it--
assumptions, or the
common sense assumptions
when we look at fMRI, and
when we look at neural signals
is that they all
mean positive things.
But maybe a lot of that
signals, a lot of activity
might be inhibitory--
might be the opposite.
NANCY KANWISHER: Totally, yeah.
But how would that explain
perceptual narrowing?
AUDIENCE: Well, if what you're
learning is what to ignore,
then maybe it takes a lot
of effort to ignore things.
And not really sure.
I'm not sure exactly, yeah.
NANCY KANWISHER: No,
it's a good point.
Like I mentioned
at the beginning,
one of the limitations
of functional MRI
is we don't know what the
actual neurophysiological basis
of the bold signal is.
It could be anything that
increases your metabolic costs,
and hence changes blood flow.
But one of the things that
increases metabolic costs
is inhibiting other neurons.
And so way back in the
early days of, actually,
PET imaging, before
functional MRI came along,
there was an early proto version
of a face-specific paper.
It didn't nail everything,
but it was not bad for 1981,
when I think it was published.
And the person who
did that paper,
Justine Sergent argued that
it's very, very ambiguous
what it means to find
a hotspot in the brain
where the activity--
the metabolic activity--
is higher, say, when you
look at faces than objects.
And her point was, that could
be the part of the brain that
really sucks at
face recognition.
That's the part
that's going, ah,
I can't deal with this thing!
What is this thing, right!
That's really bad at it, and
the neurons are firing a lot.
It's sort of facetious,
but sort of not.
And it's probably not
the right account,
but it is an important
reminder that we actually
don't know what actual
kind of neural activity
is driving those
things and whether it's
excitatory or
inhibitory, absolutely.
Hang on one second.
I feel like there was
another part of what you said
that I was going to engage on.
AUDIENCE: No, It feels
like somehow, possibly,
connected to the
perception [INAUDIBLE]..
NANCY KANWISHER: Yeah.
Yeah, possibly.
We'd have to work it out.
AUDIENCE: In one of the
lectures [INAUDIBLE],,
NANCY KANWISHER: Yeah.
AUDIENCE: And then, [INAUDIBLE]
NANCY KANWISHER: Yes.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
AUDIENCE: Then,
I'm a bit confused,
because, like, you said before,
almost like all the wiring is
[INAUDIBLE].
NANCY KANWISHER: OK,
long-range wiring.
AUDIENCE: Oh.
NANCY KANWISHER: OK?
Which is very different
than all the circuits
that live in each
little patch of cortex.
Remember, I showed
you this big change
in the complexity of neurons
and the number of connections.
Oops, looks like
we've lost it now.
So they're changing a lot within
each patch of cortex, right?
So those local circuits
that are doing computations
are surely changing a lot over
the first couple of years.
It's just the long-range
connections between that patch
and some remote region--
where it gets its inputs and
where it sends its outputs to.
But hang on a second.
You asked something-- there's
also very interesting stuff
about the other race effect.
I did mention that a
month ago or so, didn't I?
Which is another version of
this perceptual narrowing.
And in fact, a friend of mine
who's a great face researcher
has not yet
published this paper,
but she found the following.
Totally, that's right-- you
mentioned the adoption studies.
So what she has done is ask--
did I tell you guys
about this already?
I feel like I did,
but maybe not.
Anyway, so what you find
is that people are--
they all look alike.
Whoever they are, if
you've seen fewer of them
than whoever we
are, you are less
good at discriminating them.
That's just what it is.
But so Elinor McKone
asked if there's
a developmental timeline
for getting your way out
of the other race effect.
And so what she did
was-- she's in Australia,
and she got various
communities of people
who move from dominant
racial composition
x to dominant
racial composition y
and who made that move
at different ages.
And so what she finds
is that, actually,
much like learning the
phonemes of a language-- which,
even if you--
hey, let me back up a second.
I said that with phonemes,
you can discriminate
all those phonemes of all the
world's languages at birth,
and by six months,
you've thrown away
the abilities for
all the phonemes
you can't discriminate.
However, if you then go learn
a foreign language sometime
between six months
and, say, 12, you
can become a native speaker.
So you can learn
them back, right?
So there's another
window-- it gets
narrowed-- but you still have a
window to learn them back, OK?
After you're like 12,
15, whatever, forget it.
You won't be a native
speaker, right?
Same deal with the
other race effect.
This is exactly what McKone
found with the other race
effect.
People who moved to a different
dominant racial community
learned the ability to
natively discriminate people
in that other race if
they moved before age 12.
So it really seems like
there's some general ability.
Oh, I remember David's
other question.
Why does this make sense?
I don't know exactly
why it makes sense,
but certainly, neural activity
is expensive metabolically,
and we don't want to
make discriminations
we don't have to.
And so it can be just that
the nervous system is learning
what kinds of
discriminations it needs
to make in its environment and
what kind it doesn't, right?
And with the case of
phonemes, it's actually
part of what you're doing
in speech perception,
is you want to know,
every time I say "ba,"
it sounds different in
all different contexts.
And so part of the essence
of the difficulty in speech
recognition is understanding
that all those different "ba"s
are the same sound, right?
And so part of what perceptual
narrowing might be doing
is saying all those things--
"da," "ta," whatever
it is in Hindi--
those are all going to
count as the same thing.
And that's going to
help you process speech
in your native language
but hinder when you try
to learn a foreign language.
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: So something
I'm wondering
with perceptual narrowing is how
general like the starting point
is.
So I'm basically wondering--
because in the studies,
they compared human
and monkey faces.
NANCY KANWISHER: Yeah.
AUDIENCE: And I'm
wondering if there's
any correlation with
how similar the DNA,
like how they're able to
discriminate between the faces.
So whether that's
different types of monkeys,
or different animals--
NANCY KANWISHER: I'm
not getting it, right?
Early on, you can
discriminate both, right?
So what's the question?
AUDIENCE: So I'm wondering
what other animals can they
discriminate, and what--
NANCY KANWISHER: I see, I see.
How far does it go?
Yeah, good question.
I don't know that anybody
has asked little kids if they
can discriminate other kinds of
faces other than monkey faces.
I'm sure there's some limit
to it-- like fish faces?
Probably, I don't know, yeah.
But there's also, actually,
in terms of that extended--
I don't know the
answer to that, yeah.
There's going to be some limit.
But in terms of the
question of how long
can you relearn those
abilities or maintain them,
it's not like
perceptual narrowing
is going to happen at
six months automatically.
So if you manipulate it--
so the studies on humans,
if you send--
I feel like I said
this in here before,
but it must have
been somewhere else--
if you send parents
home with books
with monkey pictures in them,
parents of six-month-olds,
and you say, look,
every night, go
through the book with your kids
and say, there's Monkey Joe,
and there's Monkey
Bob, and there's
Monkey Whoever with
your kids, and you
have them do that from age
six months to 12 months,
they don't perceptually
narrow, because they continue
to get that experience, right?
Interestingly, if the
parents go home and just say,
look, look, that doesn't do it.
You have to give them some
social cue that is essentially
saying, this thing is
different from that thing.
And if you do that
with an infant,
even when they don't really
understand language much,
they get that cue, and they
learn to discriminate--
or they maintain their ability
to discriminate monkey faces.
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: Does that
hold up even when
they're past the 12 months old?
NANCY KANWISHER:
Well, I'm guessing
it will be just like the
case that McKone showed
with other race effects, right?
I'm guessing the other
species effect will
be like the other
race effect in that
if you, say, start
working in a monkey lab
when you're eight years old--
that would be weird,
but you could--
or you-- I don't know, whatever.
Anyway, that you would be able
to relearn it on the same time
scale that you would relearn--
relearn, or learn for the
first time, previously
unfamiliar races of faces.
But maybe those are slightly
different timelines.
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: Could you
do something similar
with the monkey faces,
but with phonemes
in different languages?
NANCY KANWISHER:
I'm sure you can,
and I'm sure that
has been done, but I
don't know that literature.
Yeah.
Yeah, you mean like keep--
well, OK.
I mean, it essentially
does get done, right?
So kids who stay
in environments--
let me think about this.
Well, certainly, an
infant who's being
raised in a
bilingual environment
will maintain their ability
to discriminate those phonemes
from any of the languages
they hear, right?
AUDIENCE: So you're saying, with
the monkeys thing, some kind
of social cue to know that--
NANCY KANWISHER: I
suspect that's true.
I don't know this
literature well enough.
I do know-- yeah, actually,
it's coming back dimly.
Heather, do you know this?
Janet Werker
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
NANCY KANWISHER:
OK, so Janet Werker
is this amazing infant
phoneme perception researcher.
And I'm pretty sure that
if you present infants
with just like a TV
in the background
with a foreign language, even
if the infant doesn't have much
else to do, that's not enough.
And you need to look at
them, and engage with them,
and speak mother-ese-- like,
hey, infant, blah, blah, right?
I think you need to do all of
that for them to maintain it,
but I'm--
AUDIENCE: Yeah, that's correct.
I think there also
has to be interaction.
They can't also just be
watching the [INAUDIBLE]..
It has to be
slightly [INAUDIBLE]
reciprocal [INAUDIBLE].
AUDIENCE: And the
fact that [INAUDIBLE]..
NANCY KANWISHER: Correct, yeah.
AUDIENCE: So even if it's
not just [INAUDIBLE],,
it has to be [INAUDIBLE].
NANCY KANWISHER:
It has to be what?
AUDIENCE: It has to
be like [INAUDIBLE]..
It can't be [INAUDIBLE].
AUDIENCE: Yeah, which makes me
of [INAUDIBLE] or something--
like if you interact in
different ways, [INAUDIBLE]..
NANCY KANWISHER: Cool, yeah?
AUDIENCE: Yeah, I have a
question about how long
that [INAUDIBLE] lasts.
If someone spoke
a foreign language
when they were younger,
then moved somewhere else
or were adopted and then
stopped speaking the language,
[INAUDIBLE],, could they
sort of be [INAUDIBLE]??
NANCY KANWISHER: I don't know.
I'm sure there's a
literature on that.
You don't know
that, Dana, do you?
Sorry, like so you're
raised bilingual,
and then you stop having
the experience early
on from your second
language, and then
you're re-exposed
later at age eight?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
AUDIENCE: Yeah, you
still have the--
yeah, you maintain
the [INAUDIBLE]..
AUDIENCE: Yeah, like after--
NANCY KANWISHER:
Well, but wait--
AUDIENCE: But you're not able
to speak the language, right?
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
AUDIENCE: But you
still [INAUDIBLE]..
AUDIENCE: But I guess you--
NANCY KANWISHER:
But then, that's
not consistent with
perceptual narrowing.
AUDIENCE: If you're exposed
to it before two years?
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
NANCY KANWISHER: Yeah.
AUDIENCE: And then
you move away?
NANCY KANWISHER:
Well, if it goes
beyond that six-month
thing, yeah, OK.
AUDIENCE: I think
that's the case, yeah.
You might not have
the higher structure,
but if you like you the
syntax and some vocabulary,
you'll have a better accent
than someone who did not
have that early
experience, might not
be able to differentiate
[INAUDIBLE]..
But--
AUDIENCE: You just [INAUDIBLE].
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE],,
I think that's correct.
NANCY KANWISHER: OK, good.
One more question.
Josh?
AUDIENCE: So do we
know of cases where
there's [INAUDIBLE] a mismatch
between [INAUDIBLE] sort
of information?
Like--
NANCY KANWISHER: Like this?
AUDIENCE: Yeah, like--
with this property
in some of the domain of
some of the [INAUDIBLE]..
Basically be [INAUDIBLE].
NANCY KANWISHER:
Oh, god, I don't
have my dictionary of
knowledge filed that way
so I can pull up an
instance of that,
but I'm sure there
are loads of those.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
NANCY KANWISHER: Yeah,
well, because when we--
because we're making all
these assumptions about which
behavioral ability is subserved
by some particular activation
in the brain.
And mostly, we
don't know, right?
We know when we have
the rare opportunities
to do causal tests.
We have a better
idea that that system
is at least causally involved
in that behavioral ability.
But yeah, often, those links
are much looser than we'd like.
All right, see you
guys Wednesday.